and here we got a fellow right here and
he looks a bit posh actually
hey it's david from schneiderlin wales
i've got a king in a stinger whales
castles oh kingdom bro
oh wow that's beautiful i mean it's kind
of shitty looking but yeah so being well
shaking it
there's more castles per square mile
than anywhere else in the world
uh so yeah let me know kang gang buzz
buzz
come recovery
must be the local team um dude king
castles dude get some khaleesi in there
spit out some kids run around the castle
don't see him these days oh and there i
met you mate right there oh oh yeah that
was in london man
did you give you that jacket or
something huh did he give you that
jacket
no what are you guys doing he had the
ted uh he said theo had the tags on so
he could return it
oh yeah in england smart yeah i'm still
planning on returning it
i gotta mail it back to get it returned
[Laughter]
they are tied
[Laughter]
hey different strokes for different
folks man at least you're saving money
i'm telling you as soon as ross dress
for less opens back up i'm in there
um i would say what was the man asking
again
captain king of sting castles are now
there's a kentucky castle can we look
that up there's one castle in america
called the kentucky castle and i stayed
there
oh really i stayed there whenever i was
now have you have you ever gone to uh
medieval times uh yup
that's not a real castle though brenden
yeah but it's the closest thing we have
and you eat chicken with your hands yeah
you're right good call
in the movie they're at medieval times
and he goes can i get a diet coke she
goes
dude remedial times hints there was no
diet coke
ace ventura you don't remember
brendan do you know where the cable guy
is
can i get a knife and fork and she goes
dude there are no knife and forks
hence medieval times he goes oh but
there's diet coke
dude i got a long day was a cable guy
yeah it's cable guy yeah it's cable guy
because remember he plays the character
okay i'd love to be part of this yeah
all right but i can't table the guy for
sure and there's the kentucky castle
right there and this castle in
kentucky's interesting
because here's what happened a man was
in love with a woman
built the castle for the woman and then
uh she never came back to him oh wow wow
she didn't see the pictures she she just
wasn't down
because it's a castle usually because
the old saying was
build that castle get that [ __ ]
let's build that castle get that [ __ ]
oh
damn that's aggressive yeah that is very
aggressive right
well that's the saying in kentucky i
didn't make it up well
that's why you build a goddamn castle
[Music]
is